swabra Muhammad's home city of Mombasa
produces an estimated 500 tons of
plastic waste every day much of it ends
up in the nearby Indian Ocean in its
fish and then in people who eat them
swabra helps prevent that by collecting
it from her neighbors a social
Enterprise called bous taka buys it and
sells it to
recyclers it's a good thing the
governments are meeting and we hope
they'll support us this project helps us
to clean the town and to reduce
pollution it also occupies women like me
and we earn
money people living here say bous Tacker
has helped to make the city cleaner in
recent years but the problem goes far
beyond these streets the companies that
produce and sell plastic are making
money as the world's plastic waste grows
every year here in Kenya less than 10%
of it is recycled the rest of it ends up
in the sea or in dumps like this C
campaigners say that Community projects
alone can't solve the Plastics crisis
and that the only possibility is a
legally binding International
treaty as representatives of 175
governments meet in Nairobi to continue
negotiating the UN treaty these
protesters say the problem is far from
solved countries that also beneficiaries
of oil or they produce oil you know they
may want to derail the process because
they feel we are affecting the way they
you know they the main source of uh
income therefore it is not a walk in the
park about 60 countries at the summit
are calling for binding rules to reduce
the production of plastic but major
plastic and oil producers including the
US say the focus should be on recycling
instead Rich economies have historically
produced the most plastic but poorer
countries pay the price and end up with
much of the waste the negotiations are
due to be completed next year people
people are waiting to see if the treaty
will change
that Malcolm web Al jazer Mombasa
Kenya make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer